we're known for academic rigor we're all
known for our discipline and structure
uh we have had a hundred percent of our
high school seniors get accepted to
four-year colleges and universities
since 1978.
wow
[Music]
can you believe it i'm still here that's
right living inside this tent for 100
days from november 20th to february 28th
bring to you the awareness that you need
to know about gun violence in the city
of chicago but also to raise as much
money as we possibly can on this block
called oh block it's called oh black
because it's named after a young man
named od perry who was shot and killed
we're changing to opportunity block and
we're going to build a community center
right here to change the lives of people
i'm so excited that
foxy network gives me an opportunity
every single day to bring you rooftop
revelations
where i share with you my thoughts views
and opinions and off time bring you some
special guests today i'm really really
excited to bring to you a brother who
runs one of the most fantastic schools
in the city of chicago uh where the
proficiency of reading is high the math
is high the students are excelling
excellence and they do not lower the
standards at all and i want to talk to
him about that school and i want to talk
to him about all that he does for the
great city he's on the west side of
chicago so we won't hold that against
him uh tim irving providence saint mill
tim how you doing man i'm doing great
today fast how about yourself i'm doing
great man i know you're a graduate of
purdue and all of that but uh i want to
thank you for the work that you do on at
providence st mill can you just tell us
about providence email if you would all
right providence st miller is a private
independent school on the west side of
chicago used to be a catholic school in
1978 the archdiocese was going to close
the school because of low enrollment but
the principal at the time mr paul j
adams iii said he was going to keep it
open and he kept it open he's kept it
open now for 44 years
um
as a private independent school we're
known for academic rigor we're all known
for our discipline and structure
we have had 100
of our high school seniors get accepted
to four-year colleges and universities
since 1978. wow and so we do not lower
standards that he said and many of our
students
also receive college scholarship dollars
and many of our students are accepted to
the top 50 colleges in the country
wow i know that um i want to talk about
how
how the standards are and the discipline
because
two of my children went there and they
really really needed it and i thank you
all so much but i think people will be
interested that one of your biggest
early supporters uh early on when the
school was was president reagan can you
tell us about that a little bit yes
president reagan visited the school in
the early 80s 1982 i believe and because
he heard about the success of the school
he wanted to come and visit and he also
called the school a model of success for
other schools i mean i i believe he was
quoting saying people need to figure out
how to duplicate what providence same
male was doing back in 1982-81
wow and you all
and another thing
that i don't want to gloss over
100
of y'all students
get scholarships so get go to college
get yeah yeah
tell us about it all right 100 of our
students does i mean do get uh do get
accepted into four-year colleges at the
university matter of fact the class of
2019 which is your class your son was in
yeah each one of those seniors
going to earn at least one college
scholarship to go to college it wasn't
full scholars but each one earned some
scholarship dollars to go to college
that year and so we really pride
ourselves on not just getting our
students accepted into college but
finding scholarship dollars for all of
our students not just the top students
but also the c student we have we've had
students who graduate from providence
same male with a 2.2 gpa and get a
forced tuition scholarship to a
four-year university where they where
they can finish and finish college
without any student debt i tell people
all the time a college education is
valuable but a free one is priceless i
know that's right so because you know
they and they got that scholarship
because of your standards you know i
don't want any people to think oh 2.2 or
2.4 but they don't understand how
rigorous the the the school is
when you compare probably the same mail
to other schools in chicago especially
public schools
there is a drastic difference in the in
this the quality of the students the
standards are high the dress code is
implemented but you all even make sure
that parents are involved yes we want to
make sure we keep our parents informed
we meet with our parents at least once a
quarter and we uh and whenever students
have an issue we make sure we call home
because this is a partnership the
parents have to be involved with the
education of their children and they
should want to be and because we're a
private school and the parents pay money
they they're motivated and incentivized
to be involved we have you know great
parental support uh at providence mail
because we keep them involved we're very
transparent we let them know what's
going on about the good the bad and the
ugly when it comes to their student and
so we want to make sure that we are
doing our part to keep them informed you
know one last question um tell people
about where this school is located
because those who are watching who are
outside of chicago they may not
understand uh the geographical location
but i want them to understand where this
school is thriving and where it is
probably the same located on the west
side of chicago in
east garfield park one of the toughest
neighborhoods in the city uh murder
murder crime rate is very high violence
is definitely prevalent in the
neighborhood and surrounding
neighborhoods and so our students when
they get to providence saying well they
know they're safe because the school is
built this looks like the council on the
outside and it feels like a council on
the inside and the students feel safe
when they are in there they feel safe
when they're in the school and we make
sure that we don't have any foolishness
going on inside the school and our
students are safe from the time they
walk in that building until they get in
their car with their parents or even if
they have to walk to the bus stop
man well thank you you know for over 40
years y'all been doing a great job
making sure the students go to college
making sure the students uh meet the
standards you're not lowering any
standards just to give students a quick
fix but you all keep the discipline
intact the parents involved and i want
to just take a moment just to thank you
all and and appreciate you all for what
you do thank you can i say one other
thing yes sir our open house we have an
open house this saturday at providence
st middle school 119 south central park
boulevard for um
parents who are looking for a new school
whether it's for um pre-k preschool all
the way through 11th grade we are
accepting applications for the 2022-2023
school year our open houses this
saturday january 29th at 10 a.m at
providence st middle school we invite
all uh parents to come out with their
children and see the school and see the
magic of providence st mel and what's
the website because there are people
from all across the country who are
going to check you all out so what's
your website website is um
www.psmnow.com
psmnow.com all right thanks man i
appreciate you thank you appreciate like
i always say we really appreciate it
thank y'all for tuning in today and i'll
be back with you tomorrow at the same
time on the same network fox network as
i always say
peace
peace
you